Jake Sullivan.
Most war.
Almost all wars end
in some kind of a negotiation.
The sort of World War two war
where one side complete only annihilates.
The other is very, very rare in history.
What will that that end?
What will those negotiations look like?
The Chinese have put out this.
I don't know what they're call it,
a peace plan.
It's just out it's a 12 point document
detailing its position,
calling for the end of hostilities
and the resumption of peace talks.
Is there anything to this?
What is your reaction?
Well, my first reaction to it
is that it could stop at point one,
which is respect
the sovereignty of all nations.
That's the first point in the 12 point
plan.
This war could end tomorrow
if Russia stopped attacking Ukraine
and withdrew its forces.
Ukraine wasn't attacking Russia.
Naito wasn't attacking Russia.
The United States wasn't attacking Russia.
This was a war of choice
by Putin waged upon Ukraine.
And it could end
if he simply left Ukraine.
And that is the best way for this war
to end.
Now, I cannot predict the future.
What I can tell you
is that the United States
is not going to dictate
to Ukraine how this war ends.
President Biden tells President Zelensky
and our allies
at every opportunity
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine.
It is the Ukrainians who will decide how
they proceed towards the end to this war.
Our job is to put them in the best
possible position on the battlefield.
So they are in the best possible position
to be able to do diplomacy
whenever they choose to do diplomacy.
And that is how we are going to proceed.
But I think there's one more important
point as we approach this anniversary
and is actually the anniversary
has arrived in Ukraine, and that is
Russia has already lost this war.
Russia's aims in
this war were to wipe Ukraine off the map,
to take the capital and to eliminate
Ukraine, to absorb it into Russia.
They failed at doing that,
and they are in no position
to be able to do that as we go forward.
And it is important for everyone
to remember that the courage and bravery
of the Ukrainian people
has already accomplished that objective
and the support of the United States
and our allies and partners around
the world has helped contribute to that.
But where this goes from here
is something that will play out
over the coming months.
What we know is day by day
We simply have to keep doing our job,
which is to give the Ukrainians
the tools they need to defend themselves.
So whatever
happens at the end of this war,
Ukraine is going to need a massive amount
of reconstruction and assistance.
Does the world have the capacities?
The United States have the capacity
for the kind of thing you know,
people talk about a Marshall Plan
like there was after 1945 to help Europe
rebuild.
Is that the kind of scale
we need to be thinking about?
Well, I think we associate
the Marshall Plan with a moment, right,
just as we associate
the end of the war or two with a moment.
And it looks as though recovery
and reconstruction
in Ukraine, at least for the time
being, is going to happen differently.
Just this month, earlier
this month, the world Bank announced
$50 million to invest in the repair
and restoration
of the transport networks,
the transport infrastructure in Ukraine.
And that's how U.S.
aid is proceeding as we try to catalyze
the involvement of the European Bank
for Reconstruction Development.
The big international financial
institutions and to get the private sector
to be interested
in coming back to those parts of Ukraine
that are relatively peaceful
and even to continue to make investments
elsewhere.
We just struck
a Public-Private partnership with Bayer,
which is building a new seed factory
in Ukraine, which is going to employ
thousands of Ukrainians.
The more Ukrainians are employed,
the more revenue there is the less
assistance will need to come from outside.
So this is going to be from within
and from without.
But I think it's not necessarily
going to be an on off switch.
It's something we want more
Ukrainian refugees to be in a position
to come home to have infrastructure
that awaits them
where they can live in buildings
that have been repaired.
But, of course, the damage
that some estimates is that the damage
so far has been $130 billion if you take
arable land, homes, hospitals, schools.
So this is going to be
a mammoth undertaking.
The other thing we want to do now
is with an eye to those big ticket items,
which most of which will happen
only when there is a negotiated peace.
But we have to
make sure that resources are going to be
well spent.
When you have those huge investments
which go well beyond
what is being provided right
now, that's when, of course,
you want to make sure
that you have the safeguards in place
so that all outside investors and donors
know that and can say to their citizens
that this is money
that's going to be well spent.
But I think President Biden has spoken
really eloquently, powerfully
to how much enthusiasm there will be
when this war is officially over.
You know,
a number of actors are on the outside
really wanting to be a part of the longer
term solution.
But getting the institutional frameworks
right is something we can be working on
right now.
In addition to these stopgap recovery
efforts.
Jake, I got to ask you one final question.
We've talked all about the world,
Russia, Ukraine.
We haven't talked about
what's going on in the United States.
Do you worry when you hear voices
like Governor DeSantis, Senator Hawley,
Senator Vance
questioning why the United States is doing
this, asking why we should be spending
this money, wondering whether we should be
taking a more neutral position
What I find so interesting
about that perspective, we can't
operate in the world
because we have to operate at home is it
presents a fundamentally false choice
that is not at all who America is.
We can both invest at home
and provide for the safety
and well-being of the American people.
And we can lead in the world.
And that's what we have done at our best
under Democratic
and Republican presidents for decades.
The United States is capable
as a powerful self-assured nation.
We have the resources,
we have the talents,
we have the energies of our people
to solve our own problems here.
And President Biden has done more
in two years to invest in this country,
to build jobs,
to provide for the social safety net,
to deal with the problems that people sit
around their kitchen tables
and think about while at the same time
mobilizing a coalition of free nations
to support the values
that Americans hold so dear.
So what I would say to those senators
is, yes, let's do these things at home.
But are you saying
that America is incapable of also
helping to serve a powerful force
for good in the world?
I don't think that the American people
believe that.
I think the American people think
we are capable of doing both.
And at our best,
that is exactly what we have done.
And I believe that a lot of the moments
I've seen in this last year in Ukraine,
from those flags waving in small towns
that Samantha
was talking about
to the people in the U.S.
government who are trying to support
folks like you
who are on the front lines,
that has been America at its best.
And so I think that there's a pessimism
in this argument
that these senators are making.
President Biden has an optimistic view,
which is we can do it and we should do it
and we are doing it. And as a result,
I believe that democracies in the world
are getting stronger, not weaker,
as the president said, and autocracies
are getting weaker, not stronger.
And that is better
for every single person in this country.